7,1 milliarden euro das sind 74 prozent
weniger hat der neue etwas überraschend
berufen
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister zum
erzieher den welche schon im bild sehen
und zwar hatte etwas weniger bekommen
weil er über mehr einnahmen verfügen
soll so zumindest die kurzfristige
mittelfristige finanzplanung für sein
haus also cem özdemir neuer
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister hat ja
schon gleich am anfang seiner amtszeit
gesagt dass die lebensmittel in
deutschland an und für sich zu billig
sind das ist ein altes problem gerade
was die milchbauern zum beispiel angehen
das kennen wir schon in der tat waren
die lebensmittel in deutschland wirklich
sehr sehr billig das ist jetzt auch im
zuge dieses urteil kommt kann das
geworden und befürchtet dass die bauern
nach wie vor nicht mehr geld bekommen
und der landwirtschaftsminister jetzt
hier mit seiner rede präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
in der ukraine verteidigen gegenwärtig
landwirtin landwirte irland und
versuchen unter einsatz ihres lebens
dennoch irgendwie gleichzeitig die
felder zu bestellen wenn man
ukrainischer amtskollege roman geschenke
neulich beim g7-treffen vor sandsäcken
sitzen berichtet das ist ein
aufenthaltsort jeden tag aus
sicherheitsgründen wechseln muss für den
dies vor augen warum es gerade
eigentlich geht deshalb tun wir alles in
unserer macht stehende auch mein haus
tut es um den menschen in der ukraine in
dieser schwierigen zeit beizustehen
das gewicht es von hier sagen die
hilfsbereitschaft unserer bevölkerung
ist wirklich beeindruckend auch die
unternehmen für die wir eine
koordinierungsstelle in meinem
ministerium eingerichtet haben leisten
wirklich tolles in saarn
lebensmittelhilfen über 3000 tonnen
hilfsgüter haben wird über die grenze in
die ukraine bislang gebracht deshalb
möchte ich mich an der stelle ich nehme
an im namen von allen sehr bedankt für
den unermüdlichen einsatz der vielen
engagierten der unternehmen aber auch
meines eigenen hauses
aber machen wir uns nichts vor die
auswirkungen des krieges gehen weit über
die ukraine hinaus fast 50 ländern
beziehen laut un
welternährungsorganisation ihr getreide
aus der ukraine oder aus russland um
ihre versorgung zu sichern deshalb haben
wir im rahmen der deutschen
präsidentschaft der g 7 sofort mit den
agrarministern agrarministern
gemeinsamen signal gesetzt nämlich dass
es ganz entscheidend jetzt darauf
ankommt dass die märkte offen bleiben
und der globale handelt jetzt nicht
zusammenbrechen darf den markt
unsicherheiten führen zu zusätzlichen
preissteigerungen das ist das gegenteil
von dem was wir jetzt gerade brauchen
darum ist es jetzt elementar dass wir
auch das world food programm der
vereinten nationen besser unterstützen
die welt kann sie auf deutschland
verlassen wir werden unseren beitrag
dazu leisten dass das world food
programm entsprechend ausgestattet wird
sage aber auch
ich sage aber auch ganz klar es muss
auch darum gehen nachhaltige
landwirtschaft öfter ein und
ernährungssicherheit auf der anderen
seite in den ländern auch vor ort zu
stärken
das ist doch der kern des rechtes auf
nahrung das unterstützen wir mit vielen
internationalen programm für unser land
für die bundesbank deutschland können
wir sagen die versorgung mit
lebensmitteln ist sicher
sei aber auch zu ehrlichkeit gehört dazu
wir können die folgen des krieges nicht
ungeschehen machen die sollte man das
machen mit welchen maßnahmen darum haben
wir versucht da bin ich sehr dankbar
dafür dass die bundesregierung jetzt
über weitere maßnahmen versucht unsere
bevölkerung angesichts der rapide
steigenden preise zu entlasten möchte
aber auch die gelegenheit nutzen die
bevölkerung zu bitten uns zu helfen beim
einkauf verantwortungsvoll und
vernünftig vorzugehen gerade in diesen
zeiten solidarität zu zeigen auch das
ist ein beitrag in der jetzt gezeigt
und natürlich
und natürlich hat dieser krieg auch
auswirkungen auf unser land wir haben
gemerkt wir sind verletzlich bei krisen
spüren gerade in ganz besonderer weise
unsere landwirtinnen und landwirte bei
steigenden kosten etwa für mineraldünger
oder für energie was uns große sorgen
bereitet deshalb haben wir ein erstes
maßnahmenpaket aktiv und vor allem
schnell auf den weg gebracht wir wollen
für 2022 als ausnahmeregelung den
aufwuchs auf ökologischen vorrangflächen
der kategorie brache inzwischen früchte
als futtermittel freigeben zudem werden
wir über diesen haushalt an
stellschrauben drehen die uns auf dem
weg zu einer weniger krisenanfälligen
landwirtschaft voranbringen wir werden
die bestehenden programme zur förderung
von energieeffizienz und erneuerbaren
energien in der landwirtschaft ausbauen
und gleichzeitig verbessern wir werden
unsere eiweißpflanzen strategie
finanziell aufstocken um des angebots an
regional erzeugten futtermitteln
auszubauen und nicht zuletzt wollen wir
in digitale innovation investieren damit
dünner effektiver eingesetzt werden kann
und darüber unsere landwirtinnen und
landwirte kosten sparen wir arbeiten
zudem intensiv daran bis zu 180
millionen euro für schnelle krisenhilfe
direkt auf die höfe zu bringen wir
wollen die dafür zugesagten 60 millionen
euro aus der brüsseler krisen rezepte
mit nationalen mitteln um weitere 120
millionen über den ergänzungs haushalt
aufstocken ich will dass es an der
stelle auch sagen ich zähle auch auf sie
meine liebe kolleginnen und kollegen auf
die freunde und freunde in der
landwirtschaft im parlament damit unsere
bäuerinnen und bauern in dieser zeit gut
durch die krise kommen
wir befinden uns wir finden uns in einer
lage der vielfachen grießen deshalb
müssen wir ernährungssicherheit
klimaschutz und den erhalt der
biodiversität miteinander in einklang
bringen mir meine damen und herren ohne
meister der minister muss jetzt mal
zurückstehen ich in der bundeskanzler
äußert sich jetzt in brüssel und das
werden wir jetzt live übertragen olaf
scholz nach dem g7 treffen und dem
nato-gipfel ist im schrank dabei
übersehen sie dass es genau diese
rezepte waren die uns in die vielfachen
krisen und abhängigkeit manövriert warum
wäre es genau der falsche weg den jetzt
zu gehen wir leben doch
wir leben doch gerade schmerzhafte art
und weise wir haben gerade eben über den
etat der innenministerien diskutiert
auch ernährungs und
landwirtschaftspolitik ist
sicherheitspolitik wenn wir unabhängig
werden wollen von putin braucht das
konsequente schritte hin zu einer
nachhaltigen und die wird gegenüber
krisen robusteren landwirtschaft wenn
wir den weg
einer nachhaltigen energieversorgung und
landwirtschaft schon vor zehn jahren
gegangen werden dann wären wir heute
weniger krisenanfällig ich habe einen
wunsch ich wünsche mir dass wenn wir in
zehn jahren
ich wünsche mir dass werden wir zehn
jahren mal zurückblicken dass es dann
nicht heißt hätten wir
2022 uns auf den weg gemacht in richtung
nachhaltige energieversorgung und
nachhaltige landwirtschaft sondern mache
was heute damit wir in zehn jahren
bilanz ziehen können und sagen wir haben
gelernt aus der krise wie man es besser
sein müssen wir
müssen dringend aufhört krisen
gegeneinander auszuspielen denn das
verschärfte krisen ja nun der jüngsten
weltklimabericht gab es wirklich allen
lesen sich durch spricht eine sehr klare
sprache wenn wir uns gebeten unter
wasser die artenvielfalt und das klima
nicht schützen weil wird das noch
wesentlich heftigere krise hervorrufen
und dann erst recht die
versorgungssicherheit gefährden dürren
überschwemmungen
das artensterben sind heute schon für
viele menschen in der welt realität und
haben dem urteil gesehen weit entfernt
ist es von uns nicht und wenn jetzt
schon die ersten drei wochen im märz
sehr trocken sind die landwirte und
landwirtinnen wissen wovon ich rede dann
steigt auch bei uns die sorge vor
schlechten ernten und damit vor höheren
preisen auch in dieser hinsicht ist
übernutzung nicht der richtige weg
sondern die nachhaltige nutzung von
natur und umwelt es ist auch
wirtschaftlich günstigere weg
meine damen meine herren
damit landwirtschaft eine zukunft hat
auch das vor allem landwirtinnen und
landwirte kurz vor der jahrtausendwende
zu 99 gab es noch über
470.000 betriebe bis heute ist die zahl
auf unter
265.000 gesunken und er jeden einzelnen
hof stehen familien über generationen
hinweg geschaffen die werte stehen
tradition steht vor allem auch eine
frage kommen im ländlichen raum diese
zahlen zeigen durch die bitteren folgen
einer politik die in der vergangenheit
immer nur eines gesagt hat wachse oder
weiche wachse oder weiche genau diese
geschichte von wachsen oder weichen die
dürfen wir die werden wir jetzt nicht
fortschreiben wenn wir brauchen die
bäuerinnen und bauern für die versorgung
uns des landes
in den letzten tagen hat mir eine seite
vorgeworfen ich würde den ökologischen
sündenfall betreiben weil wir die brach
mittel brachflächen für futtermittel
freigegeben haben die andere seite wirft
mir ökologische sturheit vor weil ich es
vage über umwelt und klimaschutz zu
reden ich ziehe es vor auf die
zwischentöne zu hören und denjenigen die
miteinander vernünftig arbeiten wollen
eine chance zu geben ganz im sinne der
zukunftskommission landwirtschaft und
der broadcom ist meine damen meine
herren ich muss zum schluss kommen darum
bitte ich sie unterstützen sie uns wir
haben eine erste milliarde im haushalt
eingestellt als anschubfinanzierung
jetzt wollen wir weitere schritte gehen
das königsrecht des parlaments ist
gefahren sie dürfen der agenda was
drauflegen bei allen
meinungsverschiedenheiten im detail
haben wir nach wie vor die chance auf
eine landwirtschaft die ökonomisch
ökologisch und nachhaltig ist liegt an
uns allen ob wir in zehn jahren
zurückblicken und dann sagen können
unsere saat ist aufgegangen
unsere landwirtschaft ist eine branche
für zukunfts bauer erzielen
[Applaus]
nächster redner ist wenn ich ein aufrufe
der kundige steffen bilger cdu csu
fraktion
ja sehr geehrter herr präsident lieber
herr minister liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen irgendjemand aus der grünen
fraktion hat gerade angerufen so
andächtig hätte man die unionsfraktion
noch nie erlebt es lag vielleicht auch
an der rede des herrn ministers wo jetzt
wenig konkretes drin war wenig was
gemacht werden muss wenig zu den
vorhaben dieser bundesregierung in der
landwirtschaftspolitik will aber
durchaus eingangs auch anerkennend sagen
uns haben es angesprochen was ihr
ministerium zusammen mit der deutschen
ernährungswirtschaft leistet an hilfe
für die ukraine mit den
lebensmittellieferungen das verdient
wirklich anerkennung
wir sind schon wieder mit einer
situation konfrontiert wo der
koalitionsvertrag dieser regierung nicht
vorher gesehen hat welche große krise
auf unser land zukommt auch gar nicht
vorhersehen konnte nämlich mit dem
angriffskrieg von russland gegen die
ukraine dadurch ist vieles anders und
das gilt eben auch für die ernährungs
und landwirtschafts politik von nicht
einmal einem viertel jahr haben wir an
dieser stelle erstmals grundsätzlich
über die ausrichtung der deutschen
ernährungs und landwirtschafts politik
diskutiert ich habe damals in meiner
rede deutlich gemacht dass auch unter
einem bundesminister ärzte mir die
ernährungssicherung für alle mit
möglichst fairen preisen und die
einkommenssicherung unserer landwirte im
zentrum der agrarpolitik stehen sollte
im protokoll ihrer damaligen rede lieber
cem özdemir sucht man den begriff der
ernährungssicherung vergeblich in den
ersten 100 tagen ihrer amtszeit
geradeaus ein bisschen an geklungen
haben sie viel auf die
vorgängerregierung geschimpft das paar
ging ja wirklich kaum ein tag an dem sie
nicht bei twitter oder in interviews auf
die vorgängerregierung verwiesen haben
und die vorgänger regierung versäumnisse
vorgeworfen haben viele jahre der spd
auch ein vier jahre mit der fdp in den
16 jahren denen wir jetzt verantwortung
tragen durften aber sie haben auch immer
wieder versäumt darauf hinzuweisen dass
ich alles getan hat in diesen
vergangenen jahren sie haben gerade kurz
die zukunftskommission landwirtschaft
angesprochen das gehört doch absolut zu
den erfolgen der gemeinsamen politik die
wir mit der spd gemacht haben
allein der prozess und es sagt ihnen
jeder der beteiligten egal ob
naturschutzverband
landwirtschaftsverband wer auch immer
allein der prozess war schon sehr
hilfreich ist sind konkrete ergebnisse
erarbeitet worden jetzt geht es
natürlich um die umsetzung da sind sie
in der verantwortung
jetzt für die koalition für den minister
muss es ja schon ein erwachen in der
realität der regierungsverantwortung
sein dass sicherlich besonders
schmerzhaft ist denn nun hat aufgrund
der ganzen dramatik der situation in der
ukraine ganz offensichtlich dass eben
eine hinreichende versorgung und gesunde
lebensmittel nicht nur sonntagsreden
entstehen sondern etwas mit produktion
zu tun haben mit finanziellen
rahmenbedingungen und mit dem markt das
muss wieder in das zentrum mit den
mittelpunkt ihrer landwirtschaftspolitik
gerückt werden
wenn wir wollen meine damen und herren
dass unsere landwirt in der lage bleiben
die ernährung der menschen zu sichern
dann brauchen sie planungssicherheit und
brauchen sie ökonomische luft zum atmen
und sie brauchen vor allem wertschöpfung
wertschätzung und das sollte in der
aktuellen situation doch allen klar sein
bevor es aber gerade auch schon
angeklungen der übliche rollback vorwurf
kommt nein wir wollen kein volberg in
der landwirtschaftspolitik wir stehen zu
unseren zielen beim klima und
umweltschutz bei der förderung der
biodiversität beim tirol und beim
nachhaltigen anbau
zur regierungsverantwortung gehört aber
sich auf veränderte rahmenbedingungen
einzustellen und das beste daraus zu
machen das heißt auch das ziel
beibehalten werden aber wenn es nötig
ist dann auch mal in einem anderen tempo
wurde in einer anderen reihenfolge dazu
mache ich sie auch herr minister haben
sie dafür den erforderlichen mut nicht
einfach weiter so sondern die politik
klug an die aktuellen gegebenheiten
anpassen
will jetzt an der stelle gar nicht sagen
zu ihrem vorstoß weniger fleisch zu
essen wäre ein beitrag gegen tub ihm
wichtiger als solche presse geschichten
ist doch wir alle wissen um die große
bedeutung der landwirtschaftlichen
produktion in der ukraine und in
russland für die menschen vor ort bei
uns ist auf der gesamten erde und
deshalb gilt es jetzt in einer großen
gemeinsamen kraftanstrengung die
landwirtschaftliche produktion in
deutschland und europa und die
nahrungsmittelversorgung nachhaltig
krisenfest zu machen oder anders gesagt
wir müssen auch bei uns in europa bei
uns in deutschland wieder mehr
nahrungsmittel produzieren
auf keinen fall aber sollten wir weniger
produzieren und dem rahmen der
gemeinsamen europäischen agrarpolitik
geplante flächenstilllegung von vier
wertvoll lagerfläche verbietet sich zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt meine damen und
herren
herr minister die landwirte brauchen
unterstützung beim umbau der tierhaltung
sie müssen in ihrem haushalt dafür
sorgen dass dieser umbau dauerhaft
finanziell abgesichert wird sie haben
wir gerade selbst angedeutet dass die
bisher vorgesehenen mittel dafür nicht
ausreichend sind ich gehe mal davon aus
dass sie mit ihrem koalitionspartner fdp
beim thema steuerfinanzierung nicht
weiterkommen ich glaube auch nicht dass
eine abgabe die lösung sein und also
muss das geld für den umbau aus dem
haushalt kommen sie müssen sicherstellen
dass die nötigen mittel im
bundeshaushalt zur verfügung gestellt
werden der minister
was aktuell gar nicht geht dass sie noch
mehr belastungen von seite staates die
hohen energiepreise sind dramatisch
genug und deswegen meine damen und
herren brauchen wir ein
belastungsmoratorium
ein belastungsmoratorium für die
bäuerlichen familienbetriebe für die
halter für die winzer oder auch für
unsere fischer um nur ein konkretes
beispiel zu nennen 80 des umsatzes
energiekosten bei manchen dieser
fischereibetriebe ohne konkrete hilfe
wird es für diese betriebe nicht möglich
sein den nächsten wochen zu überleben
überleben dieses beispiel zeigt mehr
denn je braucht die land und
ernährungswirtschaft einen minister der
für ihre interessen kämpft haben sie mut
der koalitionsvertrag ist angesichts der
aktuellen herausforderungen
weitestgehend ohne ihn nur noch
makulatur tun sie das notwendige in der
bundesregierung in brüssel drei punkte
will ich hier noch mit auf den weg geben
erstens die eu agrarpolitik muss die
ernährungssicherheit grundlegend stärker
in den blick nehmen zweitens der eu den
deal und die farm zu ford strategie
müssen grundlegend neu bewerten und
einer folgenabschätzung unterzogen
werden drittens es geht nachhaltige und
ökologische intensivierung mit modernen
technologien und innovationen zu
fokussieren auch meine meinung aber
aktuelles karriere ihres
koalitionspartners fdp kluge worte denen
sie folgen der minister vielen dank
[Applaus]
nicht zu reden dann ist die kollegin
esther durch die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
sehr geehrter herr minister liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in den letzten
haushaltsreden zum einzelplan des
bundesministeriums für ernährung
landwirtschaft haben wir ein augenmerk
auf die belastungen der landwirtschaft
in der korona zeit gelegt wer ganz
vielen maßnahmen darüber hinaus leben
steht ein kita-platz zu werder hat
irgendwie vorrangig zugang zu
irgendwelchen leistungen haben die
landwirte müssen aus den augen verloren
und
systemrelevanz noch nicht festgestellt
aber ich denke wir sind uns einig dass
auch diejenigen die unsere lebensmittel
produzieren nämlich unsere landwirte mit
ihren familien systemrelevant sind liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
sie arbeiten nicht etwa ein home-office
sondern täglich 24 7 bei wind und wetter
sommer wie winter auf den feldern in den
ställen
aber auch im büro weil in vielen
bereichen ausgedehnte
dokumentationspflichten bestehen und
diesen arbeitseinsätze können wir gar
nicht hoch genug wertschätzen viele
kinder kennen den beruf des landwirts
oder der landwirtin nur noch aus dem
bilderbuch wo dann manchmal der
berufswunsch reift ich werd
treckerfahrer aber söhne und töchter von
landwirten sind heute jedoch keineswegs
selbstverständlich mehr bereit die
elterlichen betriebe zu übernehmen sie
wissen nämlich mit welchen sorgen und
nöten beziehungsweise herausforderungen
ihrer eltern zu kämpfen haben
afrikanische schweinepest corona
pandemie vogelgrippe zu viel oder zu
wenig sonne so viel oder zu wenig regen
ausfall von erntehelfern umsetzung von
politischen entscheidungen und oft genug
müssen alle familienmitglieder selbst
mit anfassen weil viel arbeit zu leisten
ist aber die betriebe nicht genug
abwerfen um mitarbeitende anzustellen
die landwirte in meinem wahlkreis sind
bereit in veränderungen zu investieren
aber so sagen sie mir grad wenn ich mit
dem kreis landwirten rede sie wünschen
sich dann auch die sicherheit dass ihre
darlehen dann noch abbezahlt werden
können bevor sie dann wieder weitere
massnahmen auferlegt bekommen bevor wir
weitere maßnahmen von ihnen fordern
und sie dann vor der schwierigen
entscheidung stehen sollen wir jetzt
nach finanzieren oder sollen wir gleich
die notbremse ziehen und den betrieb
aufgeben
unsere politischen entscheidungen sollen
unsere landwirtschaft zukunftsfähig
machen und das bedeutet veränderung
aber wenn wir etwas einfordern dann muss
das auch entsprechend gefördert werden
und diese gewissheit brauchen unsere
landwirte
denn wie die kolleginnen und kollegen
diese familien liebt ihre arbeit und
wollen diese auch gerne fortsetzen im
leben gehört dass in ost generationen
betriebe und dafür brauchen sie unsere
unsere unterstützung und dafür werden
wir uns in der fortschritt ampel auch
einsetzen der zweite regierung center
für den haushaltsplan
2022 des ministeriums sieht ein gesamt
etat in höhe von 7,1 milliarden euro vor
rund 570 millionen euro weniger als 2021
aber das ist nach dem auslaufen des
zeitlich befristeten
konjunkturprogramms corona folgen
bekämpfen usw geschuldet aber fast vier
milliarden davon das heißt über die
hälfte des gesamten etats sind ausgaben
für die landwirtschaftliche
sozialpolitik also für die
alterssicherung der landwirte die
landwirtschaftliche krankenversicherung
und zuschüsse zur landwirtschaftlichen
unfall versicherung wobei hier auch
nicht unerwähnt bleiben soll dass
letztere zuschüsse von 177 millionen auf
100 millionen gekürzt wurden mit der
begründung das sei eine anpassung an die
finanzplanung und das aufgrund einer
entscheidung in der letzten legislatur
unter einer landwirtschaftsministerin
julia klöckner und das wird sicherlich
in den haushaltsberatungen noch zu
diskussionen führen
zudem
finde ich auch ist unfassbar das war
noch unter der alten legislatur das
werden wir sicherlich noch diskutieren
müssen zu den aufgaben des ressorts
gehört auch der gesundheitliche
verbraucherschutz
und ernährung und dafür sind ausgaben in
höhe von 168 millionen euro vorgesehen
zum beispiel für zuschüsse an die
deutsche gesellschaft für ernährung ev
und der größte anteil aus diesem kapitel
in höhe von 138 millionen ist die
erstattung der verwaltungskosten des
bundesinstituts für risikobewertung und
was macht dieses institut dieses
institut bewertet gesundheitliche
risiken für unsere gesellschaft und
ermittelt neue gesundheitliche risiko
für verbraucherinnen und verbraucher und
transportiert dies entsprechend in die
öffentlichkeit liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen als ob er nicht schon genug
herausforderungen im hinblick auf die
sicherstellung von gesunder ernährung
gehabt hätten kommt jetzt noch der krieg
in der ukraine dazu putins einmarsch in
die ukraine bedroht die
nahrungsmittelversorgung nicht nur hier
im land sondern von millionen menschen
weltweit
die ukraine gilt als kornkammer europas
aber dank unserer landwirte werden wir
in deutschland von lieferengpässen und
von weizen in der europäischen union
zumindest nicht betroffen sein so
äußerte sich sehr der bauernpräsident
joachim rukwied
wir haben bestimmt selbst alle beim
einkaufen schon festgestellt das
sonnenblumenöl im
lebensmitteleinzelhandel
knapp geworden ist deutschland deckt
diesen bedarf zu über 90 prozent aus
importen die ukraine dagegen ist bei
sonnenblumenöl export lang nummer eins
mit 51 prozent und auch russland hat
einen anteil von 27 prozent
nicht nur in diesem bereich müssen wir
also mit rohstoffverknappung rechnen und
wer hätte das vor dem 24 februar gedacht
ich möchte jetzt nicht appellieren
beziehungsweise unbedingt appellieren
dass sie hier nicht wieder völlig
unsinnige hamsterkäufe starten und wir
wie zu beginn der korona pandemie stadt
toilettenpapier jetzt so einen global
orten ist also eine ganz einzel bitte
auch nach außen an alle die das hören
die ländlichen räume die forstwirtschaft
und die fischerei schau mit großem
interesse auf die entwicklung des
haushalts des bundesministeriums für
ernährung landwirtschaft
dafür sind unter anderem die in der
gemeinschaftsaufgabe verbesserung der
agrarstruktur und des küstenschutzes
sogenannten back mittel veranschlagt und
sie sind überwiegend zweckgebunden in
form von sonder rahmen plänen der bund
stellt den ländern hierfür mittel bereit
die durchführung der fördermaßnahmen
überlegt über
obliegt dann den ländern einige sonnen
raumpläne sind zum beispiel
insektenschutz dafür stehen 150
millionen im haushalt förderung der
ländlichen entwicklung mit 190 millionen
verbesserung des tirols 15 millionen
küstenschutz 25 millionen und
bewältigung der durch die extremen
wetterereignisse verursachten folgen im
wald mit 120 millionen denn auch in
diesen bereichen stehen wir vor großen
herausforderungen der haushalt heißt
zwei ernährung und landwirtschaft aber
wir dürfen unsere forstwirte hier nicht
vergessen
hinter angriffen künftig mit dem wald
umgehen es gibt einige die meinen man
solle den wald in ruhe lassen damit er
sich erholt seit jahrhunderten werden
aber auch unsere wälder genau wie
ackerland bewirtschaftet
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und daran
darf sich meiner auffassung nach und
auch der auffassung meiner funktion nach
nichts ändern nur eine sinnvolle
bewirtschaftung
wird uns die möglichkeit geben unseren
wald fit für die zukunft zu machen und
ihn zu nutzen einen wichtigen beitrag
für mehr klima und umweltschutz für
erhalt der biologischen vielfalt und zur
instandhaltung natürlicher ökosysteme zu
leisten und auch für die produktion von
bauholz zb auch dafür holte sich das von
diesem haushaltsentwurf 200 millionen
zusätzlich eingestellt sind für die ja
meine damen und herren und soweit also
bundeskanzler olaf scholz der im moment
ja auch vorsitzender der g7 ist die die
handlung gemeinsamen entschlossen hat er
gesagt wir rufen den russischen
präsidenten auf endlich einen
waffenstillstand zu vereinbaren
die nato wird 40.000 mann verlegen
richtung grenze in vier battlegroups
nach in die slowakei nach ungarn
bulgarien und rumänien also die
ostflanke der nato verstärken aber ein
eingreifen der nato in dieser situation
jedenfalls wird nicht stattfinden
und wie ihr meine damen und herren wir
sind jetzt meine damen und herren hier
bei der debatte im bundestag über den
einzelplan 10 ernährung und
landwirtschaft
und
peter feßl von der afg ist jetzt der
politiker der im moment das wort ergriff
ihn an das ist richtig das ist
zukunftsweisend wenngleich es ist ein
bescheidener anfang wenn man mal mit
china oder usa
vergleicht aber immerhin wir begrüßen es
auch dass im bereich ausgewogene
ernährung investieren in bildung und
aufklärung investieren das ist gut in
zeiten von adipositas von herz kreislauf
erkrankungen
da ist das gut und richtig investiert
lieber kollege jetzt aber zu dem was vor
allem an diesem haushalt auf feld 1
plant sehen in welchem bunker in welcher
blase in welchen elfenbeinturm herr
minister haben sie eigentlich dieses
hier zusammen geschrieben das ist ja
null komma null an die aktuelle lage
angepasst wo finden sich in diesem plan
bietet die auswirkungen der korona krise
wo die derzeitige schwere inflation wo
die jünger grenze wo finden sich die
maßnahmen hinsichtlich der auswirkungen
des völkerrechtswidrigen angriff
russlands auf die ukraine davon findet
sich fast gar nichts in ihrem entwurf zu
ignorieren all diese krisen und arbeiten
einfach weiter nach ideologischer
tagesordnung so als ob nichts passiert
wäre das ist grundlegend falsch und das
lehnen wir haben
sie haben es gerade selber gesagt die
landwirtschaft steht mit dem rücken an
der wand wachsen oder weichen diese
parole hat uns sehr viel schaden
zugefügt jedes jahr schließen tausende
höfe in deutschland und die bäuerliche
familien verlieren ihre existenz
mit den explodierenden energiekosten der
betriebsmittelkosten und den junge
kosten wird das höfesterben weitergehen
mit diesem haushalt werden am ende des
jahres wieder tausende höfe ihre hoftore
für immer schließen müssen das lehnen
wir ab beenden sie endlich das
höfesterben
[Applaus]
aber liebe kollegen ist geht und es ging
er definitiv an dass frankreich hat
kurzfristig ein hilfspaket über 460
millionen euro aufgestellt damit werden
die finanziellen folgen des ukraine
kriegs für die französischen landwirte
abgemildert das sind 3 1 steuerliche
erleichterungen so geht hilfe für die
landwirtschaft österreich dänemark und
polen handeln ähnlich und sogar die eu
kommission plant jetzt noch ein
zusätzliches unterstützungspaket von 500
millionen euro und die freigabe der
krisen teams gerade gesagt warum machen
sie da hier in deutschland nicht davon
gebrauch national den landwirten zu
helfen
uns verwundert dass die bundesregierung
nur so spärlich entlastung für die
heimische landwirtschaft vorgesehen
haben das wäre aber dringend
erforderlich
es kommt ja auch noch dazu dass sie die
bundeszuschüsse zur landwirtschaftlichen
unfallversicherung von 77 millionen euro
jetzt gekürzt haben wo soll das
hinführen
aber nochmal zur aktuellen lage wir
haben krieg in europa kriege
unmittelbarer nachbarschaft und erhalten
sie es nicht für geboten herr minister
die nationalen getreidereserven für
krisenzeiten aufzustocken jahrelang
wurde hier gespart große teile der
bestände sind überlagert und liegen
schon länger als zehn jahre
sie sind gar nicht mehr nutzbar so ein
zustand ist nicht hinnehmbar dass liebe
kollegen das ist das gegenteil von
krisenvorsorge
gewesen vorsorge hieß jetzt aber auch
dass wir auf allen landwirtschaftlichen
flächen lebensmittel anbauen dürfen
setzen sie jetzt in dieser situation
setzen sie bitte jetzt die ohnehin
falschen vorgaben aus richtig die
ökologischen vorrangflächen müssen jetzt
bewirtschaftet werden aber nicht nur
dieses jahr sondern bitte auch in den
nächsten jahren die instrumente dazu
gibt uns brüssel ja auch an die hand und
die anderen länder machen das genauso
unsere landwirte dürfen hier nicht
weiter eingeschränkt werden zu sprechen
von der 4 prozent zwangs brache nächstes
jahr ausgesetzt sie muss aber für immer
verhindert werden weil wir das kommt das
habe ich ihnen diesen irrsinn können sie
keinem mehr erklären
4 prozent das entspricht 4,2 millionen
hektar in der europäischen union und
diese aus ein aus ideologischen gründen
einfach stillzulegen das wäre der
absolute wahnsinn das können sie keine
mehr erklären
nur zum vergleich das er auf diesen
flächen könnten über 25 millionen tonnen
weizen angebaut werden marokko ägypten
tunesien als jähnigen äthiopien diese
länder benötigen zusammen knapp 28
tonnen weizen pro jahr da sehen sie
wohin das führt liebe kollegen in afrika
verhungern menschen bei uns steigen die
preise in den himmel in dieser lage
weiter an ihre ideologie festzuhalten
das wäre völlig unverantwortlich und am
montag haben die ersten bauern bereits
angekündigt sie werden diesen irrsinn
durchbrechen sie werden für die
hungernden menschen weist anbauen und
daneben illegal anbauen so weit sind wir
schon das haben die landwirte
angekündigt
kommen sie endlich in der wirklichkeit
an kanzler scholz vollzieht seinen 180
grad werden in der verteidigungspolitik
im wirtschaftsministerium davon wieder
etwas lauter über laufzeitverlängerungen
für die kernkraft nachdenken leiden
ziehen jetzt bitte im ministerium eine
agrarwende ein eine agrarwende die
unsere bauern schützt und die für unsere
bürger jederzeit gute und gesunde
lebensmittel zur verfügung stellen kann
das wäre und das ist das gebot der
stunde vielen dank
peter felser war das für die afg
fraktion der bundestag debattiert den
etat ernährung und landwirtschaft des
neuen landwirtschaftsministers in cem
özdemir aus dessen rede weiter wir
vorhin ja leider raus gehen musste hat
sie mir hat noch einmal die prioritäten
der künftigen
landwirtschaftspolitik genannt und nicht
darüber kommt jetzt von der fdp er ist
mitglied im ausschuss pressechef
kollegen
es wird viel von zeitenwende dieser tage
gesprochen insbesondere da außen und
sicherheitspolitik aber ich glaube auch
in der landwirtschaftspolitik
stehen wir vor einer zeitenwende
das umdenken ist erforderlich weil wir
den fokus stärker auch auf die
ernährungssicherheit als wichtigen
standortfaktor für deutschland und für
europa sehen müssen
und ich glaube dass
das man dass dadurch am besten erreicht
indem man die landwirte die bäuerinnen
und bauern in deutschland
als unternehmer
respektiert und ihnen die voraussetzung
schafft dass sie mit ihrer hände arbeit
auch tatsächlich wirtschaftlich
erfolgreich sein können und dafür wollen
wir die voraussetzungen schaffen wir
wollen eben nicht mit der gießkanne wie
ist die vorgängerregierung mit der
bauern milliarde gemacht hat einfach
geld unter die menschen verstreuen
sondern es muss die rahmenbedingungen
müssen gesetzt werden damit die
landwirte auch tatsächlich eine zukunft
haben
derzeit sind die landwirte vor ganz
schwierigen voraussetzungen gestellt die
vorgängerregierung hat immer wieder
durch
gesetzliche rahmenbedingungen
unsicherheit geschaffen es gab keine
planungssicherheit für die landwirte
darunter darunter haben sehr viele
betriebe gelitten jetzt sind die
schweinepreise zwar wieder angestiegen
und die weizenpreise wieder angestiegen
aber
gleichzeitig stellen wir fest dass
dünger dass diese das erdgas
entsprechend
ja noch stärker ansteigen und deshalb
die landwirte aus ihrer situation nicht
wirklich
bessere voraussetzungen haben und darauf
hat die koalition heute reagiert wir
haben heute
verkündet dass wir die energie steuer
auf europäisches mindestmaß reduzieren
wollen das hat auswirkungen auf den
dieselpreis wir haben das hat auch
auswirkungen auf den ölpreis das heißt
das sind ernste und konkrete maßnahmen
wo wir glauben dass wir auch den
landwirten für ihre situation durchaus
helfen können und auch die
auch die energie pauschale von 300 euro
hilft auch den landwirten auch der
familien zuschuss für die kinder hilft
auch den landwirtschaftlichen familien
also ich glaube da haben wir durchaus
heute etwas vorgelegt was man durchaus
vorzeigen kann im einzelplan 10
haben wir auch die
eiweiß pflanzen produktionsstrategie mit
5,6 millionen auf 5,6 millionen erhöht
die digitalisierung in der
landwirtschaft wird auf 51,4 millionen
erhöht und wir haben auch eine erhöhung
der förderung im präventiven
hochwasserschutz auf 100 millionen
erhöht aber
umweltschutz muss mit augenmaß
stattfinden es darf nicht die
wirtschaftliche grundlage der landwirte
entziehen und hier ist es notwendig
finde ich dass die gap reform als die
gemeinsame agrarpolitik
in dieser schwierigen situation die
geplante vierprozentige flächen
reduktion noch mal überprüft für
deutschland bedeutet das dass
700.000 hektar künftig nicht mehr
bewirtschaftet werden rechnerisch
könnten so
4 millionen tonnen weizen produziert
werden
landschaft landschaft verbindung also
der verein hat jetzt in meiner
heimatregion petershagen im kreis
minden-lübbecke dazu eine bemerkenswerte
aktion gestartet wo sie auf einem feld
entsprechend diese vier prozent
eingezeichnet haben als verzweiflungsakt
und deutlich zu machen dass sie
lebensmittel produzieren die gebraucht
werden die auch weltweit gebraucht
werden um die ernährungssicherheit der
menschheit zu sichern
wir müssen insgesamt landwirtschaft als
unternehmer verstehen und entsprechend
eingriff ins eigentum der landwirte
vermeiden wenn wir das tun dann muss
auch der staat dafür geradestehen und
finanzielle mittel bereitstehen wenn
jetzt die eu in den krisen reserve vor
wie es der minister vor ihm auch gesagt
hat
entsprechend diesen vor aktiviert dann
muss auch klar sein dass man historische
fehler nicht doch noch einmal macht ich
glaube wenn der staat lagerkosten für
schweinefleisch und für andere produkte
letztendlich
finanziert dann ist das der falsche weg
diese produkte müssen auf den markt
sonst erleben wir wie im letzten
jahrhundert futter sehen und milchseen
und butterberge ich glaube das wäre der
falsche weg da muss man am ende wieder
langwierig darauf setzen die
marktmechanismen den gang zu setzen das
wäre aus meiner sicht der völlig falsche
weg was unsere landwirte
was unsere landwirte jetzt brauchen ist
verlässlichkeit
wertschätzung und vor allem ein
moratorium an vorschriften daran wollen
wir als fdp und in der koalition
arbeiten vielen dank
ein motoren- und vorschriften das hört
sich gut an entbürokratisierung aber
wird das nicht seit jahren und
jahrzehnten in quasi allen
politikbereichen versprochen und wenn
man dann mal in neue gesetze schaut dann
ist genau das gegenteil meist der fall
ich sagen so wir sehen die nächste
rednerin wie sie mir sie ist
stellvertreter
fraktionsvorsitzende der linksfraktion
und haushaltspolitische sprecherin
vielen dank frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren der
weizenpreis geht durch die decke kostete
eine tonne weizen anfang februar
264 euro sind es zu dieser woche bereits
376 euro und hungersnöte bedrohen
millionen von menschen und was tut die
bundesregierung effektiv gegen diese
note herr minister diese frage haben sie
nicht beantwortet
sie wollte im rahmen der deutschen g7
präsidentschaft dafür einsetzen dass die
märkte offen bleiben und der globale
handel funktioniert doch wie wollen sie
das machen wo ist im bundeshaushalt das
geld eingestellt um die weizenpreise zu
drücken wir haben es nicht gefunden
meine damen und herren
marktgläubigkeit
hilft nicht weiter der amazon
kapitalismus heute bestellt morgen
geliefert ist nicht nur hoch riskant
sondern lebensgefährlich und vorsorge
dafür diese bundesregierung kein
fremdwort sein und da bin ich schon bei
den ökologischen vorrangflächen folgen
wurden brachen genannt ich fand es
wichtig und richtig dass diese flächen
gesichert wurden und nun sollen sie ein
teil dieser flächen für die
futterproduktion freigeben ich frage sie
wäre es nicht viel sinnvoller 100
milliarden euro sondervermögen land in
das grundgesetz zu schreiben das wäre
gut für unseren jungs sicherheit
in den vergangenen 15 jahren haben sich
die preise für ackerland verdreifacht
gerade in ostdeutschland haben
investoren franz müntefering von der spd
nannte sie einst heuschrecken vielen
gehören und beuern das arbeiten
unmöglich gemacht und stadt ökologische
flächen zu bewirtschaften
sollten sie das land kaufen und
preiswert verpachten das wurde den
bäuerinnen und bauern helfen und die
ernährung langfristig sichern wir
brauchen ein kreis deckels ackerland
besser wäre es noch wenn grund und boden
gemeineigentum wären das wäre wirklich
nachhaltig meine damen und herren
für wen bei der damen und herren ist die
lebensmittelversorgung in unserem land
wirklich gesichert der hartz4 satz hat
schon vor der krise nicht zum leben
gereicht mit steigenden preisen für
energiekosten und lebensmitteln wird es
für viele menschen eng und bedrohlich
sie müssen für einen inflationsausgleich
sorgen und sofort den hartz iv satz
anheben und die mini renten das wäre der
richtige weg meine damen und herren ich
bin mir sicher ein sondervermögen
ackerland würde und langfristig mehr
sicherheit bringen als ein
sondervermögen rheinmetall rheinmetall
denn es geht nicht um die bundeswehr
sondern um die aktienkurse von
rheinmetall nur aktien kann man leider
nicht essen vielen dank
ja und diese argumentation hören wir in
allen auswärts titeln von der linken ein
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr da
kann ich doch auch zum beispiel eines
für ackerland und landwirtschaft geben
allerdings ist diese sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr ja nicht dazu geeignet
die bundeswehr auch zu rüsten um dann
ein anderes land zu feiern sondern um
gegenüber fälle gerüstet zu sein
sebastian schäfer jetzt für die
bündnisgrünen
frau präsidentin sehr geehrter herr
minister man ist sehr verehrten damen
und herren wir führen diese debatte hier
während menschen in der ukraine aufgrund
des krieges hungern und keinen zugang zu
frischem trinkwasser haben es geht für
die menschen um existenzielle fragen das
dürfen wir bei allen innenpolitischen
debatten nicht vergessen
ich bin
der müsste mir sehr dankbar dass er
schnell reagiert hat und eine
koordinierungsstelle für
lebensmittelhilfen eingerichtet hat
darüber bereits mehr als 3000 tonnen an
lebensmittelhilfen in die ukraine
geliefert wurden aber die auswirkungen
des krieges beschränken sich nicht nur
auf die ukraine russland und die ukraine
werden möglicherweise längerfristiger
als getreideexporteure ausfallen die fao
die ernährungs und
landwirtschaftsorganisation
der vereinten nationen rechnet infolge
des ukraine krieges mit einem
20-prozentigen anstieg der weltweiten
lebensmittel und futter preise das hat
dramatische folgen gerade für die länder
des globalen südens insbesondere in
ostafrika die besonders abhängig von
russischen und ukrainischen getreide
importen sind daher ist es richtig dass
der landwirtschaftsminister angekündigt
hat sich gemeinsam mit der
außenministerin dafür einzusetzen das
world food programm besser auszustatten
um so einen globalen ernährungskrise
entgegenzuwirken
unsere lebensmittelversorgung und
deutschland ist gesichert es gibt keinen
grund für hamsterkäufe und dennoch
spüren unsere landwirtinnen und
landwirte der anlage schon vorher alles
andere als einfach war die auswirkungen
dieses schrecklichen krieges die preise
für diese aber ganz besonders auch für
dünger sind nach oben geschnellt
und dennoch wir dürfen jetzt nicht den
fehler machen krisen gegeneinander
auszuspielen die klimakrise ist und
bleibt eine menschheitsaufgabe
deshalb stellen wir in diesem haushalt
die weichen für energie formen der
landwirtschaft und eine tirol
orientierte nutztierhaltung das bedeutet
weniger tiere in den ställen und das ist
auch richtig so der übermäßige konsum
von tierischen erzeugnissen ist ein
problem für die gesundheit für die
umwelt und für die
lebensmittelsicherheit ab 20 23 stellen
wir eine milliarde euro als
anschubfinanzierung zur verfügung um den
klimafreundlichen und tiergerechten
umbau der tierhaltung entscheidend
voranzubringen und wir ermöglichen mit
der kennzeichnung der
haltungsbedingungen mehr marktwirtschaft
auch hier müssen wir eine jahrelange
blockade der union auflösen die
bürgerinnen und bürger können dann mit
einer informierte kaufentscheidung die
zukunft unserer landwirtschaft
mitgestalten es ist eine gewaltige
herausforderung vor der wir bei der
landwirtschaft und bei der ernährung der
welt stehen wir werden das nur gemeinsam
schaffen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
und es folgt für die cdu/csu-fraktion
die kollegin christina stumpe
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister liebe kolleginnen
kollegen meinen vorrednerin und
vorredner haben es bereits bereits
gesagt doch ich möchte noch einmal
darauf hinweisen weil man es gar nicht
häufig genug sagen kann sie stocken im
haushalt das personalbudget um 20% auf
und die land- und forstwirtschaft hat
die abstriche zu verkraften ich möchte
deshalb
ich möchte deshalb gerne aufzeigen wo
das geld in ihre person nötiger
gebraucht wird als ein aufbau eines
beamtenapparats der deutsche wald ist
die grüne lunge und wichtiger
klimaschützer unseres landes sbr bindet
rund 14 prozent des jährlichen co2
ausstoßes außerdem ist eine ist ein
wichtiger wirtschaftsfaktor und sichert
viele arbeitsplätze im ländlichen in den
ländlichen regionen
seine bedeutung aber auch seine
gefährdungen nimmt durch den klimawandel
ständig zu deshalb müssen wir den wald
der zukunft jetzt gemeinsam gestalten um
die wälder klima resistente aufzuforsten
sind im vorliegenden haushalt für den
zeitraum
2022 bis 2026 nun 900 millionen euro
vorgesehen das sind 180 millionen euro
pro jahr zwar ist es eine grundsätzliche
unterstützung für den umbau unserer
wälder begrüßenswert aber dafür wird das
geld bei weitem nicht reichen das dünne
institut geht davon aus dass wir dafür
in den kommenden 30 jahren insgesamt 14
milliarden euro notwendig sein werden er
sogar 43 milliarden euro weil dürre
stürme und borkenkäfer plage von jahr zu
jahr zunehmend werden
bricht man den betrag auf die jahre
herunter bedeutet das dass wir für den
waldumbau zwischen 466 millionen und 1,4
milliarden euro pro jahr veranschlagen
müssen 180 millionen sind da viel zu
knapp bemessen und somit ein tropfen auf
den heißen stein
die frage wie die honorierung von
ökosystemleistungen auf eine nachhaltige
waldbewirtschaftung pragmatisch erfolgen
soll ist noch offen aber eines ist
gewiss auch dafür werden wir öffentliche
gelder bereitstellen müssen das hat
selbst die eu mit der waldstrategie
2030 festgehalten
aber wir brauchen nicht nur gelder für
den waldumbau ist sondern auch im
bereich der tierhaltung wenn wir den
gesellschaftlichen anforderungen oder
forderungen für mehr tirol nachkommen
wollen werden wir dafür natürlich
finanzielle fördermittel notwendig sein
denn ohne zusätzliche gelder kann auch
in diesem kann auch dieser umbau nicht
gelingen
die bundesregierung will eine
verbesserte tierhaltung erreichen indem
sie sich für eine verpflichtende
herkunftskennzeichnung und eine eu weit
einheitliche regelungen 1 setzt die eu
will diese option für weitere bestimmte
lebensmittel prüfen und gegebenfalls bis
zum vierten quartal 20 22 einen
vorschlag vorlegen aber vom warten
werden keine stelle umgebaut und nicht
mehr tierwohl erzeugt
frankreich hat es im rahmen eines
modellprojektes vorgemacht aber ab dem
ersten märz diesen jahres müssen dort
auf restaurants kantinen die herkunft
des angebotenen schweine- geflügel- und
lammfleisch angeben
wir brauchen in deutschland deshalb eine
kombination von tierhaltung und
herkunftskennzeichnung fünf dem was
garantiert dass das jeweilige tier in
deutschland geboren aufgezogen gemästet
geschlachtet und verarbeitet wurde und
zwar so schnell wie möglich
das gibt unseren verbraucherinnen
verbrauchern die notwendige gewissheit
und sicher das tierwohl unsere landwirte
und landwirte brauchen dafür
rechtssicherheit beim baurecht und
emissionsschutz aber eben auch vögel
denn mehr tirol wird sich nicht durch
den ladenpreis finanzieren lassen
die borchers kommission hat hierzu
vorschläge für die finanzierung gemacht
beispielsweise über eine höhere
mehrwertsteuer für alle fleischprodukte
die konzepte liegen auf dem tisch setzen
sie sie bitte um
nicht nur die box kommission hat bereits
hervorragende arbeit geleistet auch die
zukunftskommission landwirtschaft kurz
zkm hat ausgezeichnete vorschläge
ausgearbeitet damit unsere heimische
landwirtschaft auch weiterhin ein
starkes und wertvoller bestandteil in
unserem land bleiben kann dafür so die
zecke lvds wertschätzung wertschöpfung
die steigerung des klima und
umweltschutzes und der biodiversität
sowie wirtschaftliche tragfähigkeit und
planungssicherheit für die
landwirtschaft und insbesondere für
unsere junglandwirtinnen und
junglandwirte
die empfehlungen dafür wurden im
spannungsfeld von agrar umwelt und
gesellschaftspolitik gemeinsam errungen
deshalb sollten diese kompromisse der
zkb unbedingt in die arbeit der
regierung mit einbezogen werden
der wandel unsere landwirtschaft ist
eine gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
ökologisches handeln muss in
ökonomischen erfolg umgesetzt und
finanziell angemessen unterstützt werden
die zettel hat gezeigt wie sinnvoll
runde tische sind sehr geehrter herr
minister ich möchte da zum abschluss
noch den appellen ziel richten berufen
sie jetzt einen lebensmittel gipfel ein
die auswirkungen des schrecklichen
krieges in der ukraine zeigen uns auch
hier in deutschland wie fragil der markt
ist sie zeigen uns dass alle voneinander
abhängig sind und gerade in solch einer
schwierigen situation wie dieser oftmals
zu wenig verständnis für die nöte der
anderen haben deshalb brauchen wir jetzt
unter einbeziehung der politik einen
runden tisch die dritte zum schmidt den
vertretern der gesamten
wertschöpfungskette vom acker über die
ladentheke bis hin zum verbraucher
auch kollegin sie müssen wir zum schluss
kommen denn nichts sagte
agrarwissenschaftler und
friedensnobelpreisträger norman borlaug
mit leeren mägen um menschlichen elend
kann man keine friedliche welt aufbauen
umweltpreisträger kann man
aber achten sie bitte ein wenig auf ihre
zeiten
meine damen und herren mittlerweile
halten sie es hier den vorsitz
übernommen sie ist wieder genesen
analoge wolfgang kubicki und das ist
sicherlich gute sitzt mehr
bundestagspräsident zur verfügung stehen
in dieser doch sehr
langwierigen haushalts
die nächste rednerin
payback vieles blieb
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
meine damen und herren in dem spruch der
mensch ist was er isst liegt sehr viel
wahrheit drin und deswegen brauchen wir
eine ernährungs strategie kaum ein
politikbereich betrifft die menschen in
unserem land so unmittelbar wie die
ernährungs- und landwirtschaftspolitik
das merken wir gerade in diesen tagen
noch mal mehr wir alle wollen ein
gesundes essen auf dem tisch haben doch
in der praxis ist es oft gar nicht so
einfach dass wir etwas ändern müssen das
sind wir uns alle einig es liegt also
nicht an der zielsetzung
gesunde ernährung zu angemessenen
preisen transparenz für den verbraucher
klimaschutz und nachhaltigkeit unserer
lebensmittel eine artgerechte
tierhaltung eine angemessene entlohnung
unserer landwirte bisher ist es aber
leider so die einfachste und billigste
wahl beim essen und beim einkauf es oft
die ungesunde will ich für die
hersteller aber teuer für unsere
gesundheit und unsere umwelt
die folge
krankheiten die durch eine unausgewogene
ernährung begünstigt werden nehmen in
deutschland stark zu es gibt einen
deutlichen trend zu übergewicht und
adipositas und dadurch zu herz und
kreislauferkrankungen
ein großes problem ist er viel zu hohe
versteckte zuckerkonsum in deutschland
liegt dieser deutlich über der
empfehlung der whu die ampel steht für
eine neue ernährungspolitik die auf
gesundheit und nachhaltigkeit setzt und
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher viel
stärker als bisher unterstützt
lernen gehört eine umfassende ernährungs
strategie bis 20 23 es muss für alle
leichter werden sich gesund zu ernähren
unabhängig vom bildungsstand herkunft
und finanziellen möglichkeiten
studien zeigen dass sich insbesondere
kinder aus sozial benachteiligten
familien ungesünder ernähren und
häufiger von ernährungsbedingten
krankheiten betroffen sind für mich
steht fest eine wirksame und nachhaltige
ernährung strategie muss insbesondere
diese kinder in den blick nehmen denn
gesunde ernährung ist auch eine frage
sozialer gerechtigkeit
die strategie ist es wäre ernährungs
umgebung zu schaffen das bedeutet
einfacher zugang zur nachhaltigen
angeboten
verständliche informationen mehrpreis
anreize für nachhaltigere wahl zu dem
baustein der ernährungs strategie
gehören modellprojekte für eine
kostenlose und gesunde und nachhaltige
schulverpflegung
keine an kinder gerichtete werbung für
ungesunde lebensmittel mit zu viel
zucker fett und salz ein verpflichtender
niedrig
europaweit verpflichtende
reduktionsziele für zucker ungesunde
fette und salz der blick in die
nachbarländer wie großbritannien zum
beispiel zeigt dass dies nicht zu lasten
des geschmacks gehen muss
diese längst überfälligen ziele wollen
wir möglichst schnell in die tat
umsetzen denn auch für die
ernährungsbedingt ernährungsbereich gilt
wir haben kein erkenntnis- defizit
sondern an handlungs dicke zieht
wissenschaft ärztin den fachverbände
krankenkassen und verbraucherschützer
innen fordern schon lange ein umdenken
in der ernährungspolitik
zumal ernährungsbedingte krankheiten
jährlich rund 70 milliarden an
gesundheitlichen folgekosten verursachen
70 milliarden
es ist also eine gesamtgesellschaftliche
aufgabe es geht um die gesundheit und um
die entwicklungschancen unserer kinder
und jugendlichen ein weiter wie bisher
ist die teuerste lösung
damit es für alle leichter wird sich
gesund zu ernähren drehen wir an vielen
stellschrauben
dazugehört gesunde produkte finanziell
attraktiver zu machen und das angebot
ungesunde produkte
müssen entsprechend ihrer folgekosten
teurer auch die verursacher der
folgekosten müssen mehr zur
verantwortung gezogen werden
außerdem wollen wir eine pflanzen
basierte proteinreiche ernährung fördern
weniger fleisch und weniger tierische
produkte insgesamt sind gut fürs klima
und für die gesundheit im rahmen der als
pflanzen strategie wollen wir
pflanzliche alternativen stärken vielen
dank für die unterstützung
meine damen hat wären aber das ist für
mich ein aktiven gestaltete
ernährungspolitik es geht nicht darum
dass uns der staat vorschreibt was wir
essen sollen sondern es geht darum dass
er die rahmenbedingungen aus
sozialpolitisch schafft damit eine
gesunde ernährung für alle leichter
möglich ist an dieser stelle möchte ich
auch noch mal betonen wie wichtig daher
eine ressort übergreifende
zusammenarbeit erst an der ernährungs
strategie soll neben dem bmw l auch das
gesundheits- umwelt- sowie arbeits und
sozialministerium beteiligt werden ich
freue mich darauf zusammen mit unseren
ernährungsminister dezimiert und meine
kolleginnen und kollegen aus der ampel
koalition den aufbruch der
ernährungspolitik
voranzubringen vielen dank
da müssen die anderen erst mal im namen
des - ist nun
[Applaus]
wirtschaftsminister
geht ist hier der einzelplan 10
71 milliarden euro fließen in diesen
bereich die nächste rednerin kommt von
der fdp
riege chinesin sie ist im
haushaltsausschuss und im ausschuss für
arbeit und soziales
[Applaus]
der minister meine damen und herren
viele vorredner haben bereits betont wie
wichtig eine funktionierende
landwirtschaft und die
versorgungssicherheit mit lebensmitteln
für unser land ist dass wir gerade in
diesen turbulenten zeiten aufs
schmerzlichste art und weise uns vor
augen geführt wir debattieren hier ein
ernstes im jahre 2022 ob bei uns
lebensmittelknappheit droht oder
lebensmittel rationiert und unbezahlbar
werden das zeigt uns allen wie ernst die
lage aber herr minister eine
funktionierende landwirtschaft braucht
den finanziellen rahmen und
zukunftssicherheit um uns mit wertvollen
lebensmitteln zu versorgen
vor allem benötigt die landwirtschaft
einen finanzrahmen der die anpassung auf
die gegebene situation wiedergibt
entwurf lässt mich an ihrer absicht und
ihren worten erheblich zweifeln
im größten posten landwirtschaftliche
sozialpolitik hat die ampel den größten
einschnitt in ihrem ministerium gemacht
ein minus von mehr als 250 millionen
euro gegenüber 20 21 ihre erklärung dazu
laute im wesentlichen dass sie ein
stärkeres absinken der rentenempfänger
im bereich landwirtschaft erwarten und
sich an den panini bedingt ausgefallenen
rentenanpassungen im jahr 2021
festklammern sie missbrauchen hier die
ausnahme situation der letzten jahre und
neben den landwirten ihre ohnehin
geringe altersvorsorge weg das ist genau
das gegenteil einer zukunftsorientierten
landwirtschaft
nicht nur bei der altersvorsorge auch
bei dem zuschuss zur unfallversicherung
gibt es sehr große einschnitte das haben
wir heute schon gehört von 176 millionen
im vorjahr sinken diese auf 100
millionen in ihrer erklärung führen sie
aus dass dies bei einem beispiel betrieb
zu einer mehrbelastung bei den unfall
versicherungsbeiträgen von mehr als 22
prozent führt es ist nicht nur ein
versehen oder ignoranz nein sie gehen
hier mit vorsatz vor und belasten die
land wurde zusätzlich und das ist in
diesen zeiten unverzeihlich
auch auf der normativen ebene legen sie
den landwirten immer mehr steine in den
weg ob es die düngeverordnung ist die
rahmenbedingungen für die
familienbetriebe der aufdruck angepasste
mindestlohn all dies machen sie und ihre
kollegen in brüssel das
bürokratiemonster eu bringt viele bauern
zum verzweifeln vor allem wenn diese in
der konkurrenz innerhalb und außerhalb
der eu bestehen wollen wir sehen ja
gerade in diesen tagen wie verheerend es
ist wenn wir von importen komplett
abhängig sind jetzt kommen noch die
gestiegenen dieselpreise hinzu die die
bauernbetriebe extra stark treffen und
gerade in deutschland ins unermessliche
steigen ihre politik ist eine
naturkatastrophe für die landwirte eine
katastrophe in die den namen ampel trägt
paradoxerweise erkennen sie die fehler
ihrer entscheidung und lindern die
finanziellen auswirkungen in der
landwirtschaft denn selbst über
bundesprogramm stichwort
gemeinschaftsaufgabe verbesserung der
agrarstruktur und des küstenschutzes
diese mittel steigen um 173 millionen
euro auf insgesamt über 1,3 milliarden
euro an darauf kann man dann natürlich
stolz sein aber viel geld hilft eben
auch nicht immer viel besonders wenn man
nicht kontrolliert wofür es ausgegeben
wird und ob wirklich eine kofinanzierung
durch die länder erfolgt der
bundesrechnungshof hat bereits mehrmals
angemahnt stärker beziehungsweise
überhaupt einmal zu kontrollieren
auch wir im rechnungsprüfungsausschuss
mussten uns bereits damit befassen und
haben ihr ministerium aufgefordert hier
diese praxis zu ändern meine damen und
herren lassen sie mich kurz
zusammenfassen dieser einzelplan ist
eine zumutung für alle landwirte in
deutschland der es geprägt von kürzungen
dort wo es keineswegs angebracht ist und
vor allem it ausgaben die ähnlich wie
koalitionsvertrag luftschlösser in den
himmel baut die ganze wohlfühlen ideen
aller klima formen die einführung neuer
ämter wie den tierschutzbeauftragten &
co können wir uns in diesen zeiten nicht
mehr leisten in zeiten in denen sich die
bürger die frage stellen müssen ob es
morgen noch etwas zu essen gibt oder
panisch hamsterkäufe tätigen klingt
einsatz von ihnen michael minister ich
zitiere weniger fleisch zu essen werde
einen beitrag gegen putin äußerst
zynisch wir sind in einer krise lassen
sie ja entsprechend an und stellen sie
dort geld zur verfügung wo es benötigt
wird damit eine versorgungssicherheit zu
jeder zeit gewährleistet ist ich bedanke
mich
[Applaus]
und das wort erhält für die fdp-fraktion
der kollege karlheinz busen
frau
präsidentin meine damen und herren darf
zunächst in meinem kollegen gero hocker
der ansicht gestanden hätte gute
genesung wünschen auch um bekommen hat
ihn erwischt und alles gute gero
ja liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
wir wissen alle die kammer in europa die
brennt und der ukraine krieg hat nicht
nur
die schweren folgen der gewinnerin der
energieversorgung sondern auch in der
lebensmittelversorgung die
getreidepreise haben wir gehört wo sie
hingehen und wohin zu punkten
sonnenblumenöl herkommen soll ist
fraglich und der wahl ist auch im
heimischen anbau von ölsaaten der ist
stark rückläufig
und da haben wir noch einiges zu klären
und schon heute ist klar dass die
strategien der landwirtschaft und in der
ernährungspolitik da sind wir uns alle
einig überdacht werden muss und ein
verzicht ein verzicht auf ungefähr 13
prozent der produktion der laut der
falschen strategie die kommen soll die
können wir uns im moment auch nicht
erlauben und ich bin froh dass der
frankreichs präsident makro die
herausforderungen auch erkannt hat und
damit in der europäischen union voran
geht dem beispiel sollte deutschland
folgen also flächenstilllegung können
wir uns jetzt weniger erlauben denn je
es ist
es ist ein guter und richtiger schritt
dass der bundeslandwirtschaftsminister
cem özdemir angekündigt hat ökologische
vorrangflächen für die
lebensmittelproduktion auch freizugeben
aber damit die maßnahme nicht
wirkungslos bleibt muss auf diesen
flächen unbedingt auch pflanzenschutz
zur anwendung kommen dürfen oder es
handelt sich nicht
und es handelt sich hier nicht das muss
ich ausdrücklich hier auch sagen es
handelt sich nicht um pflanzengift es
handle sich um pflanzenschutz und ich
bin mir sicher der druck
flächen zu bewirtschaften statt sie
stillzulegen wie bin ich jeden tag des
krieges größer die preise für
lebensmittel steigen massiv während wir
in deutschland nur etwas tiefer in die
tasche greifen müssen sind die menschen
in ärmeren ländern akut einer hungersnot
bedroht die entwicklungsministerin vor
schulter bereits eindringlich auf die
hungersnot hingewiesen und herr minister
sie es wollen selbst auch gesagt was da
auf uns zukommt und die knappheit von
lebensmitteln dürfen wir durch das
festhalten überholter vermeintlich
nachhaltiger strategien nicht noch
weiter befördern
auch beim grimme zeigt sie wie abhängig
wir von den mehr in der ukraine und
russland sind und die tierhaltung die
uns wertvollen dünger im sinne der
nachhaltigen kreislaufwirtschaft liefert
brauchen wir deshalb mehr denn je die
bundesregierung fehlt mehr für die
investitionssicherheit der betriebe tun
mehr für die beschleunigung der
genehmigungsverfahren und wir werden
mehr für die wirtschaftliche
nachhaltigkeit von betrieben vor allem
auch in der tierhaltung in deutschland
tun
meine damen und herren herausforderung
gibt es nicht nur in der land- geschäft
sondern auch in der forstwirtschaft in
deutschland wird vor allem schnell
wachsendes narros gebraucht angepflanzt
wird aber überwiegend langsam wachsendes
laubholz gleichzeitig werden nadelhölzer
aus russland importiert was im moment
aber auch sicher in der zukunft
nicht mehr möglich sein wird die
heimische industrie spürt bereits jetzt
dass die nachfrage nach sibirischer
lärche tot ist und nicht mehr zu
bekommen ist und diese praxis müssen wir
auch überdenken nadelholz muss in
unseren wäldern mindestens 60 prozent
ausmachen zum baum wird nunmal nadelholz
gebraucht das team institut hat
errechnet dass bei der fortführung des
weltraum baus bis 2100 der nadelholz
anteil von heute ungefähr 70 prozent auf
weniger als 30 prozent zurückgeht es
wäre ein auch ein fatales signal importe
weiter auszuweiten erst recht von
ländern die den regenwald demontieren in
deutschland dürfen weitere waldflächen
auch nicht stillgelegt werden wir
brauchen für ein klima isolierten wald
ebenso klima robuste und auch nicht
heimische baumarten
naja der koalitionsvertrag auch nur
papier was auch überarbeitet werden kann
die zeitenwende wir erleben muss die
notwendigen schritte in der land und
forstwirtschaft nach sich ziehen und wir
die bundesregierung wird daran arbeitet
vielen dank
herr and bösen sprecher für forschung
jagd politik der fdp hatte die lacher
auf seiner seite im bundestag debattiert
im einzelplan 10 ihren und
landwirtschaft und die nächste
sprecherin kommt von der links fraktion
ina latendorf hier sehen wir sie sie
sprecherin für landwirtschaft ländliche
räume und tierschutz
[Applaus]
präsidentin kolleginnen und kollegen im
januar hat gerade wie gerade eben auch
der minister eine flammende rede zu
agrarpolitischen herausforderung
gehalten aber danach ist dieser etat
eine einzige enttäuschung
die kürzung zum vorjahr um
570 millionen ist aus meiner sicht ein
skandal ist stehen 71 milliarden euro um
zahn nach abzug der mittel für rente und
krankenversicherung gerade noch 3,3
milliarden nur 3,3 milliarden für
gestaltung also für mehr tierwohl
verbesserte arbeitsbedingungen bessere
lebensverhältnisse im ländlichen raum
ich sage hier werden versprechen
gebrochen die alten probleme wie
insekten schwund tirol defizit sterbende
wälder und mehr sind alles andere als
abgeräumt krone asp sind hinzugekommen
wir haben nahrungsmittel und energie
preiserhöhung eine lösung der alten und
neuen probleme ist mit den
veranschlagten mitteln einfach utopisch
gesichtspunkte ist ich wusste dass
plätze sind tatsächlich 100 milliarden
euro da dieses geld wäre viel viel
besser angelegt bei
investitionsförderung unterstützung für
bäuerinnen und bauern oder beim
umsteuern für eine gesunde ernährung für
eine soziale und ökologische
landwirtschaft aber das ist ihnen alles
nur 3,3 milliarden wert eine schande
angesichts der weltweiten
nahrungsmittelkrise wäre eine elementare
stärkung globaler zusammenarbeit
erforderlich und was machen sie sie
kürzen die mittel für die
hilfsorganisation der vereinten nationen
fao und anderer partner von 12,7 auf
11,2 millionen im einzelplan 23 ist es
noch schlimmer geht uns der hunger in
der welt nichts mehr an herr minister
ich schlage vor sie nehmen die gelder
die sie in die staatliche förderung von
agrarexporten stecken und unterstützen
damit die welthungerhilfe und die r v
für eine echte entwickeln und noch ein
punkt ich bin zum ländlichen raum
vorkommen groß geworden lebe im
zweitgrößten flächenland deutschlands
die kürzung um rund 15 millionen euro um
bundesprogrammen ländliche entwicklung
hat mich wirklich erschrocken
und das bei vorhaben die dazu dienen
sollen ländliche räume als attraktive
lebensräume zu erhalten ehrlich gesagt
ich und meine fraktion halten das für
blanken hohn mit diesem wetter ist eine
moderne neue agrarpolitik für die
zukunft nicht zu machen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
und für seine erste rede im deutschen
bundestag erhält jetzt das board niklas
wagen nach bis 19
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen herr minister und
seinem wald gibt es so schlecht wie nie
die ökologische und politische
trockenheit der vergangenen jahre haben
dazu geführt dass nun um uns herum in
brandenburg schon wieder die
zweithöchste warnstufe ausgerufen wurde
das zeigt wie in so vielen bereichen hat
uns die union infolge ihrer
fehlgeleiteten klimapolitik eine weit
politische kahlschlag fläche
hinterlassen
als ampel stehen wir hinter den wald
eigentümerin die ihren wald zu einem
klima stabilen und artenreichen
mischwald umbauen wir wollen in diesem
jahr 200 millionen euro bereitstellen um
diejenigen zu honorieren die die
ökosystemleistungen des waldes also den
beitrag der wälder zum klima hochwasser
trinkwasserschutz und vielmehr durch
eine nachhaltige bewirtschaftung
voranbringen wir wollen motivieren
gemeinsam für den wald anzupacken und
auch bei der geplanten novelle des
bundeswaldgesetzes gilt für uns das
motto regeln nicht um zu verhindern
sondern um zu ermöglichen
meine damen und herren
tagtäglich setzen sich förster
bürgerinnen waldeigentümer und
naturschützerin für das beste in unseren
wäldern ein nur die politischen
mehrheiten in diesem lande hatten den
wald aus den augen verloren in den
vergangenen 30 jahren wurden 60 prozent
des personals in deutschland abgebaut
zeitgleich verdoppelte sich die rewe
population in unseren wäldern meine
damen und herren das wild gehört zum
wald wie die butter aufs brot nur ist es
wie so oft im leben trägt man zu dick
aufhört es irgendwann ungesund dass
jedes jahr
hunderte millionen euro fördergelder die
für das bäumepflanzen in den wäldern
ausgeschüttet werden häufig direkt in
den mägen von wildtieren landen ist
nichts anderes als
steuergeldverschwendung
lassen sie uns also gemeinsam dafür
eintreten dass die gepflanzten bäume
erfolgreich aus dem leser heraus und zum
wald der zukunft heranwachsen
kolleginnen und kollegen
putins furchtbarer krieg trifft die
menschen in der ukraine hat
die wichtigen und richtigen sanktionen
treffen am ende auch den holzmarkt das
zeigt einmal mehr wie wichtig es ist in
der holz und sägeindustrie
regionale wirtschaftskreisläufe zu
stärken die ampel verfolgt genau dieses
ziel und wird mit einer holzbau
initiative vor ort die langlebigere
nutzung des wertvollen klima rohstoffs
holz voranbringen
lassen sie uns gemeinsam
für den wald eintreten er braucht uns
mehr denn je ich danke ihnen
eine punktlandung bei der ersten rede
herr kollege das sollten sie so
beibehalten
vielen dank und
als nächster redner hält das gar nicht
das war hier mit seiner ersten rede und
einer minute der
bundestagsvizepräsidentin das kann auch
nicht jeder von sich sagen
jetzt für die cdu/csu es im ausschuss
und heimkehr der bundesminister debatten
um den agrarhaushalt sind immer so eine
grundsätzliche aussprache der
agrarpolitik von einer
regierungskoalition und einer opposition
wenn ich mir aber jetzt sie reden
redebeiträge der fdp anschaue frage ich
mich seid ihr eigentlich mitglied der
ampel bei
diesen redebeiträgen da frage ich mich
schon wie es die welchen
koalitionsvertrag unterschrieben habe
oder sind diese redebeiträge hier nur um
sich zu rechtfertigen den enttäuschten
bauern draußen die euch bei der
bundestagswahl ihre stimme gegeben haben
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren in
diesen tagen bei csi gesprochen von
einer zeitenwende sein wenn in der
sicherheitspolitik in der außenpolitik
in der innenpolitik wir haben wir müssen
auch von einer zeitenwende in die
agrarpolitik reden
in der ukraine gibt es kaum noch
menschen
die tagtäglich sich um tiere kümmern die
feldarbeit machen weil sie an der front
stehen in der ukraine wird darüber
diskutiert sollen wir denn diese jetzt
in traktor in den mähdrescher geben oder
in dem band sein dass wir in diesen
zeiten über so etwas diskutieren müssen
in europa das ist schon das bewegt mich
einfach und vor allem
haben auch wir als deutsche und als
europäische gemeinschaft eine
herausforderung nicht nur was die
sicherheitslage in der ukraine angelangt
sondern auch was die ernährungslage in
der europäischen gemeinschaft und
weltweit anbelangt und in dieser ampel
koalition steht in diesem
koalitionsvertrag von der
ernährungssicherung kein einziges wort
da hat euch der koalitionsvertrag
eingeräumt meine damen
ich begrüße es wenn auf europäischer
ebene darüber diskutiert wird die
greening auflagen zu locker über die
vierprozentige stilllegung zu reden ab
aber ich bitte auch darum ich bitte
darum dass die bundesregierung hier auch
schnell handeln denn unsere bäuerinnen
und bauern wollen sehen wie wollen sie
die sämaschine anzuhängen im märzen der
bauer nicht im mai juni oder juli wenn
agrarrat ist es zu entscheiden es ist
jetzt die entscheidung jetzt müssen die
flächen freigegeben werden jetzt muss
gehandelt werden und meine damen und
herren wir
wissen dass auf diesen flächen zwar
nicht die große menge an gebaut werden
das aber kann aber wir müssen auch
überlegen wie wir zukünftig weiter
arbeit es ist wichtig dass wir eine
selbstversorgung bekommen in deutschland
aber wir haben auch eine internationale
verantwortung wir sind hier in einer
kunst lage wir sind hier in einer kunst
ladung wir kennen anderen menschen auf
diese welt auch mit unseren produkten
mit unseren hochwertigen hochwertigen
produkten ernähren und das ist auch
unsere aufgabe dafür wir stehen
uns bereits angekündigt worden wir
stehen vor einer großen herausforderung
viele länder gerade in nordafrikanischen
bereich haben die herausforderung dass
sie kein getreide keine ende mehr
bekommen und
deshalb nein
und deshalb
ich weiß nicht ich weiß was sie fragen
wollten aber und deshalb ist es für uns
im lichte wir stehen am vorabend einer
humanitären katastrophe wenn ich nach ob
nach nordafrika schau wir haben hier als
deutsche politik eine verantwortung
diesen drohenden hungerkatastrophe zu
verhindern und das sind alle in der
bundesregierung gefordert nicht nur der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister auch die
bundesentwicklungsministerin
auch der bundeskanzler das sind wir alle
gefordert hier antworten zu liefern und
die ich sehe diese antworten leider
gottes noch nicht
meine damen und herren lassen sie mich
aber auch einen punkt erwähnen den der
minister angesprungen hat das thema
wachsen oder weichen
wenn ich wiederum in diesem
koalitionsvertrag
steht ein aspekt drin der wenn wir das
umsetzen
wieder ein bauernsterben produzieren es
ist der verbote anbindehaltung bei
milchkühen und ich bitte darum dass man
den umbau der tierhaltung auch mit den
notwendigen finanzmitteln die
notwendigen finanzmittel dazu bereit
stellt hier brauchen wir auch für
kleinbäuerliche betriebe die notwendige
unterstützung da die umbauen wollen von
einem anbieter steigen handel aufstellen
die brauchen unsere unterstützung da ist
mir noch viel zu wenig finanzmittel
hinterlegt
wenn es gerade um eine
landwirtschaftsfonds geht die wir sehr
gerne haben nämlich die weite
tierhaltung da brauchen wir war auch
eine antwort darauf wie wir damit
umgehen wenn neue herausforderungen auf
die weite die heute kommt zu kommen und
das ist das thema wolf ja und liebe fdp
vielleicht sind ja einige jäger in der
fdp darunter können sie dann in den
koalitionsgesprächen auch dafür sorgen
dass man den wunsch entsprechend im
bestand regulieren kann ich setze da
ausnahmsweise auf die bundesregierung
wir sehen auch eine große
herausforderung es ist mir in dieser
debatte ist auch ganz offen eigentlich
zu wenig über das thema ernährung
gesprochen worden denn wir als landwirte
die deutsche landwirtschaft produziert
hervorragende lebensmittel es ist
wichtig dass diese lebensmittel auch
konsumiert werden aber es muss auch eine
ausgewogene ernährung stattfinden und zu
einer ausgewogenen ernährung gehört auch
der bereich dazu den wir im
tagesordnungspunkt davor diskutiert
haben nämlich der sport und
bewegungsbereich es muss alles wieder
mobilisiert werden gerade nach dieser
corona pandemie und das ist uns alle
aufgabe viel herzlichen dank
das hat die brüske zurückweisung sehr
sportlich genommen und es folgt jetzt
für die spd-fraktion die kollegin sylvia
lehmann
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
nach zwei jahren der pandemie bekämpfung
mit großen konjunkturprogrammen und mit
leicht veränderten
ressortzuständigkeiten der neuen
regierung stellen wir im bereich
ernährung und landwirtschaft bewusst
keinen neuen rekord aus halt auf eben
nicht nach dem prinzip höher schneller
weiter
mit diesem haushalt stellen wir uns
unserer verantwortung behalten
gleichzeitig die gegebenen wort
versprechen ein
stärker als bislang müssen wir die
landwirtschaftliche produktion an die
wirtschaftlichen sozialen und
ökologischen prinzipien der
nachhaltigkeit ausrichten
hierbei geht es um die welternährung den
ökologischen landbau die biologische
vielfalt und das tierwohl all das
spiel der bundeshaushalt 22 wieder
der neu ausgerichteten nationalen
strategieplan für die gemeinsame
agrarpolitik liegt der europäischen
kommission vor er beinhaltet einen
stärkeren ausbau des ökologischen
landbaus auf 30 prozent
bis 2027 den 30 milliarden euro zur
verfügung die sich auf 40 millionen
menschen den ländlichen räumen auswirken
und für 300.000 betriebe relevant werden
können die gemeinschaftsaufgabe
verbesserung der agrarstruktur und des
küstenschutzes ist das wichtigste
nationale förderer ins der
haushaltsansatz steigt und beläuft sich
auf 1,3 milliarden euro
ich hoffe dass ich vor allem die
landwirtinnen und landwirte über den nun
um 65 millionen euro höheren etat für
den insektenschutz freuen ich jedenfalls
freue mich sehr ich kann mich noch gut
an die diskussionen und letzten jahr
erinnern
wir stärken die ackerbau strategie und
stocken diesen titel um weitere 3
millionen auf 18,5 millionen euro auf
gleichzeitig verpflichten wir uns bis
2025 weitere neun millionen euro in
anspruch zu nehmen
hiermit möchten wir den landwirten und
land würden wege aufzeigen wie sie
künftig ökologisch verträglicher
ökonomisch tragfähige und sozial
ausgerichtet habe ackerbau betreiben
können
73 millionen euro investieren wir in
forschung und innovation
damit investieren wir beispielsweise in
die digitalisierung in die pflanze
strategie und in innovative züchtung
strategien mit solchen
forschungsprojekten erhöhen wir auch den
selbstversorgungsgrad unseres landes und
schützen uns vor den auswirkungen
schwerer krisen im ausland
wir alle kennen die schrecklichen bilder
aus der ukraine und wissen dass dieser
krieg weltweite auswirkungen hat
wir spüren sie in den supermärkten und
an den tankstellen
menschen anderer länder und kontinente
finden sich vor um ihn humanitären
katastrophen wieder
die versorgung in deutschland ist
gesichert doch für uns ergeben sich
internationale verpflichtungen
auch
wenn einige das nutzen wollen um
notwendige erneuerungen über bord zu
werfen
die welt ändert sich nicht zurück wir
halten am
transformationsprozess fest ich danke
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
die ihr leben an meine damen und herren
und da sieht es für ein schattenspiel
sehen nicht nur dass in berlin die sonne
schön scheint sondern die glaskuppel die
konstruktion über diesen plenarsaal mit
hunderten von spiegeln filtert das licht
nach unten und so gegen späten
nachmittag jetzt steht das nicht
tatsächlich genau auf dem regen so der
nächste redner ist jetzt josef rief von
der cdu csu er ist mitglied im
bauausschuss
[Applaus]
segnete frau präsidentin
säge der minister liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geld geben kann nach den
vielen ankündigungen von ihnen
harmonisch in den ersten 100 tagen war
ich doch verwundert als ich den entwurf
für den agrarhaushalt gelesen habe im
wesentlichen nämlich setzen sie unsere
politik fort sie kurz ihn in einem
bereich beträchtlich bei den
sozialleistungen der antwort von einem
verpflichtenden tierwohl label wie im
koalitionsvertrag bleibt fast nichts
übrig natürlich weiß jeder können sie
sagen es krieg dieser wird nicht nur
militärische folgen haben sondern auch
die weltweite ernährungssituation stark
beeinflussen die aussenministerin sprach
gestanden von einem konkret sie
empfehlen den menschen öffentlich gegen
putin doch weniger tiere zu halten und
weniger fleisch zu essen betrifft die
verringerung der nutztiere nur die
nutztiere oder auch die millionen
haustiere
was soll das bringen tiere fressen gras
und für den mittel oftmals die oftmals
abfallstoffe sind und sie liefern uns
ganz wichtig in der jetzigen zeit
düngemitteln in der praxis hat man den
eindruck dass viele hier handeln nach
dem motto was kümmert mich krieg und
weiter ich kaufe mein brot beim bäcker
von dem ansinnen die lebensmittelpreise
sollten sinken habe ich jetzt nichts
mehr gehört ich bin gespannt wie das
möglich sein soll es gibt auch
änderungen im agrarhaushalt sie kürzen
die zuschüsse zur landwirtschaftlichen
alterssicherung um 106 millionen und zur
landwirtschaftlichen krankenversicherung
um 70 millionen weil sie eine geringere
belastung erwarten gleichzeitig ich
schon gesagt wagen steigen die
personalkosten auf nie dagewesene
436 millionen euro
nach dem motto mehr geld für die
verwaltung weniger für die bäuerinnen
und bauern privat kann ich da nur sagen
wenn der zuschuss zur unfallversicherung
slate steigt der beitrag um 14
prozentpunkte für die bäuerlichen
betriebe in der aktuellen situation ist
das einfach in exakt habe ich rufe die
koalition auf in den haushaltsberatungen
mindestens wieder auf den alten stand
von 177 millionen euro zukommen
und wie geht es mit dem zukunft und
investitionsprogramm weiter die
landwirte wollen investieren und warten
ebenso wie händler und die industrie
darauf auf die nächsten förderrunde nich
kann nachvollziehen dass für dieses jahr
der bar einsatz zugunsten der
verpflichtungsermächtigungen verringert
wurde wir müssen aber sicherstellen dass
wie die bis 2024 gegebenen zusagen
einhalten und das programm zu ende
finanzieren dieses programm ist für
unsere betriebe und die gesellschaft
sogar eine win win
win situation es macht erstens moderne
technik erst erschwinglich es leistet
einen beitrag zum klimaschutz zb durch
verringerte ausgasung und sorgt für eine
bessere ausnutzung von namen dünger und
pflanzenschutzmitteln zur cemat
cma nachfolge agentur der zuschuss
findet sich ebenfalls nicht mehr
sehr geehrter herr minister ich vermisse
auch eine deutsche initiative zur
förderung von tirol stellen wie von
ihnen für dieses jahr schon angekündigt
ist wir haben mit dem corolla
konjunkturpaket 300 millionen für stahl
und bereitgestellt wir sind genau teure
haltungsbedingungen einseitig in
deutschland müssen ausgeglichen werden
wieso wollen sie das eigentlich erst im
jahr 2023 angehen den insektenschutz
haben sie exakt in der höhe der mittel
nach den plänen der großen koalition
fortgeführt sehr geehrter herr minister
sie waren der verantwortung in diesen
kriegstagen mit ihrem handeln nicht
gerecht die eu
die eu stellt deutschland 60 millionen
hilfen zur verfügung dass sie das
vertrauen habe ich heute gehört ist
richtig aber insgesamt zu wenig und da
gebe ich normal meiner linken kollegin
recht man kann weder von aktien noch von
geld herunterbrechen
ist rot hunger in europa und in afrika
spätestens im herbst das muss uns allen
klar sein es ist da ein ergänzungs
haushalt angekündigt ich bin gespannt
was da drinnen steht haben nichts zu tun
sie alles dafür gegen die absehbaren
getreide jungs fälle aus der ukraine
entgegen zu steuern kommen sie nicht mit
der aushebelung des insektes schutzes
und des umweltschutzes oder dass wir
gegen den klimawandel jetzt zurücktreten
wollen russische panzer werden für die
extensivierung und biete was infizierung
riesiger flächen in der ukraine sorgen
viel viel mehr als uns allen hier lieb
ist
der landwirtschaftsminister der ukraine
ist sie haben das zitiert habe nicht da
haben uns ja geradezu angefleht alles zu
tun ich zitiere einen hunger sturm zu
verhindern unterstützen sie höhere anken
in diesem jahr statt zu extensivierung
geben sie unter anderem brachflächen und
geeignete grünen landflächen wenigstens
für wenige jahre für den sommer
getreideanbau respektive sommerweizen
frei die bauern in deutschland sind in
der lage mehr zu erzeugen man muss sie
nur lassen die zeit drängt denn hunger
im herbst zu bekämpfen handeln sie nicht
verantwortungslos handeln sie jetzt
herzlichen dank
vielen dank und
als nächste rednerin erhält für die
spd-fraktion an nach versaut es geht das
wort
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister liebe kolleginnen
der demokratischen fraktionen sehr
geehrte damen und herren gimme gimme
gimme more seit 2007 schon britney
spears dabei ging es sich aber nicht um
biotope und feuchtgebiete genau dafür
wäre das aber ein gutes motto über 95
prozent aller moorflächen in deutschland
sind trocken gelegt und könnte man
meinen na ja morgen machen zwar nur 3,6
prozent der landfläche deutschlands aus
wann aber 2009 10 46 prozent der
deutschen treibhaus emissionen
verantwortlich
zum vergleich das entspricht von der
menge her knapp 30 prozent der
gesamtemissionen der deutschen industrie
moore sind erst mal quasi wie ein
kompost im garten biomasse doch zerfällt
im nassen war die biomasse durch die
mangelnde luftzufuhr nicht sondern
bildet auf und bindet darin
treibhausgase gesünder topf nimmt wasser
auch zum beispiel bei
starkregenereignissen
gleichzeitig haben durch ihre
feuchtigkeit auf einen kühlenden effekt
auf ihre direkte umwelt und bei
hitzewellen entstehen durch verdunstung
wieder regen wollten moore sind an
unseren natürlichen verbündeten vor ort
um die auswirkung der klimakrise zu
bekämpfen
durch trockengelegte moore um wie
eigentlich gestopften
zersetzungsprozesse der biomasse nun
doch statt damit die tiere nun mengen an
treibhausgasen wie co2 lachgas und
methan das entspricht 40 prozent der
emissionen der deutschen landwirtschaft
die gute nachricht ist aber wir können
da was machen wir können moore wieder
vergessen nasse moorish doch nicht nur
die emission
ungefähr 20 jahren nehmen sie als
gesunde moore auch co2 aus der luft
wieder auf wir können aber nicht alle
moore wieder vergessen sonst würde unter
anderem das hannoversche rathaus
versinken ich kenne einige leute die
hätten ja was dagegen
drei von vier quadratmetern sind als
trockene moorflächen landwirtschaftlich
genutzt durch wiedervernässung verlieren
wenn die aber nicht als produktive
flächen für die landwirtschaft denn
wieder vernetzung ist nicht gleich
renaturierung
wir können auch wieder verletzten wurden
zum beispiel photovoltaikanlagen
errichten beide tierhaltung betreiben
übrigens auch beides in kombinationen
oder in sogenannten paludikultur
rohrkolben und schwarz allen anbauen man
kann auf nassen hoch wo an torfmoose
anbauen und damit der garten
bauindustrie einen alternativen rohstoff
zu torf kokos oder holzfasern bieten
strom fleisch biogas bau und
dämmmaterial und gleichzeitig speichern
wir richtig große mengen co2 demi moore
ich bin froh dass wir im haushalt des
bundesministeriums für ernährung und
landwirtschaft mittel zur förderung
eingeplant haben aber auch im klima- und
transformations- frau hahn der mittel
zur förderung von palo die kulturen zur
unterstützung der landwirtinnen und zum
ausstieg aus den torfabbau eingestellt
denn [ __ ] muss das
klima wandel und transformation sind
aber nicht nur auf chemo relevant
sondern unter anderem auch für die
fischereien der zustand der nord- und
insbesondere der ostsee ist alarmierend
18 prozent der ostsee sind tote zonen da
gibt es quasi kein leben mehr die
fischbestände insbesondere dorsch und
hering kollabieren es ist aber verkürzt
und falsch auf die fischer in als
schuldige zu zeigen die ursachen dafür
sind multi kausal und hängt vor allem
damit zusammen wie umwelt- und
klimapolitik auf den verschiedenen
ebenen den letzten jahrzehnten gelaufen
bzw nicht gelaufen ist unser bedarf an
fisch wird steigen er ist relativ co2
armen und braucht wenig futter es ist
aber illusorisch dass wir unseren
kompletten bedarf aus nord- und ostsee
decken deshalb müssen wir überall massiv
ausbau der landgestützten aquakulturen
reden die fischer in insbesondere die
kutterfischer haben außerdem mit den
aktuellen spritpreisen sehr zu kämpfen
es lohnt sich schlichtweg nicht für sie
raus zu fahren wir unterstützen als
fortschritts koalition unsere fischer
ändern herausforderungen beim umbau der
oft veralteten flocken und wo gewünscht
beim umbau aus aquakulturen damit die
bestände und nord und ost sie sich
erholen kann durch den wechsel haben
sich die verhandlungen um die quoten auf
europäischer ebene noch einmal erschwert
wir brauchen aber europäische lösungen
den beständen hilft es nichts wenn wir
hier die quoten runterschrauben andere
staaten sie aber dafür entsprechend
erhöhen wir werden deswegen zeitnah eine
zukunftskommission fischerei ins leben
rufen das haben wir uns im
koalitionsvertrag vorgenommen gemeinsam
mit den praktika in vor ort schaffen wir
eine gute perspektive für diese wichtige
branche vielen dank
wie war das für die spd zum einzelplan
10 ernährung und landwirtschaft jetzt
der letzte redner in der debatte er
kommt von der spd johannes schätze er
ist mitglied im ausschuss für ernährung
und landwirtschaft und im ausschuss für
die teils
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen wir alle sind
hier angetreten um landwirtschaft neu zu
denken ich habe diese diskussion jetzt
90 minuten aufmerksam verfolgt und ich
muss zugeben ich bin schon ein wenig
erstaunt über so manche äußerungen oder
zustimmungen vor allen dingen von ihnen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der union
sie wollen jetzt offensichtlich und das
ist meine zusammenfassung ihrer
forderungen alles daran setzen eine
maßgeblich von ihnen geprägte politik
eine politik die aber in vielen
bereichen nicht zum ziel geführt hat
nochmal vorzusetzen und ich habe es mir
notiert sie sagen zwar dass haben sie
erwähnen sie wollen keinen roll back im
nächsten satz haben sie aber sofort
gesagt wir müssen das tempo verringern
also haben sie davon gesprochen dass wir
die gleichen ziele haben heute nicht
hier sie wollen brachflächen freigeben
ökologische ziele noch einmal
zurückstellen und die new green deal
noch mal
überplanen achtung spoiler das wird
nicht funktionieren
ich gebe ihnen eher recht die probleme
die haben sie teilweise richtig
formuliert nur ich kann ihnen bei der
schlussfolgerung nicht recht geben wir
müssen auf die landwirtinnen und landete
hören und ja die haben sorgen sie
sprechen über gestiegene diese preise
gestiegene düngerpreise über hohe
rohstoffpreise bis hin zur frage die an
verfügbarkeit aber die einzige antwort
auf diese probleme kann doch sein dass
wir diese probleme nachhaltig lösen und
das können wir nur wenn wir ressourcen
schonen und ökologisch arbeiten
und egal ob wir es precision farming
digital pharming oder smart farming
nennen um diese ziele zu erreichen und
nachhaltige landwirtschaft zu
ermöglichen brauchen wir vor allen
dingen eines wir brauchen eine digitale
landwirtschaft
deswegen ist es folgerichtig dass die
bundesregierung einen haushalt vorgelegt
hat der gerade im digitalen bereich noch
einmal um über 40 prozent erhöht wurde
es stehen 51,4 millionen euro zur
verfügung mit diesen 51,4 millionen
haben wir es in der hand den digitalen
wandel von dem kollegen hammer 2018
vollkommen richtigerweise sagt er sei
größer als die umstellung vom pferd zum
schlepper diesen wandel zu gestalten und
wir brauchen dieses geld wir brauchen
dieses geld um eine daten plattform zu
schaffen die drachen ist für
projektförderungen und studien wir
brauchen es auch um das haben sie vorher
erwähnt für investitionsförderungen vor
allen dingen in kleine und
mittelständische betriebe um diesen
hohen diese hohen investitionskosten zu
bezahlen und wir brauchen dieses geld
für aus- und weiterbildungsmaßnahmen nun
mit dem vorgelegten haushalt haben wir
dieses geld zur verfügung
vom pferd zum schletter wird jetzt also
vom schlepper zum sensorgesteuerten agra
roboter die heutige verwendung von
digital möglichkeiten ist aber nur die
spitze eines enormen eisberg ist das
potenzial von digitalen agrartechnologie
es ist gewaltig und wir werden es nutzen
das neue zeiten der landwirtschaft es
war zeit nicht mehr ab und es hat schon
vor jahren begonnen und jugend nun liegt
es an uns liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen die chancen die uns die
digitalisierung bietet zu nutzen und
diese koalition wird das tun
weiter braucht diesen einzelnen liegen
nicht vor